if you are planning a ribbed band that's
going to be doubled, maybe for a neck
band, here's a tip to try.
Add a turning row for a more defined edge.
When you reach the halfway point of your
band, knit two rows on the main bed only
and slip the ribber stitches.
Then finish knitting the band.
In this example, you can see that this
creates a crease. But you can
also see the slipped strands.
In this 1x1 example,
we also get the crease.
and
the slipped strands aren't as noticeable.
In this example, I only slipped one row.
The crease isn't as defined.
This technique is an improvement over
just folding the ribbing in half.
But please take a time to give this
a try before using it on a project.
and
let me know what you think.